-Our next guest is an activist
author and six-time NBA champion
as well as the league's all-time
leading scorer.
His documentary,
"Fight the Power:
The Movements
That Changed America"
premieres on the History Channel
June 19th.
Let's take a look.
-After meeting Dr. King
and, you know,
really getting into
his philosophy,
I saw where the power was in it.
It really embarrasses
and totally takes the face awa
from oppressors
when they're shown
to be the bullies that they are.
-Please welcome to the sho
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
Thank you so much
for being here, Kareem.
-Nice to talk to you, Seth
-So, this is a documentary
about the history of activism.
And you were someone
who embraced it very early
in your career where it wa
maybe less commonplace
than we see it now.
How does activism in sport
today reflect to what
you were going through
when you were getting started?
-Well, when I was
getting started,
I had several great examples
in front of me.
Muhammad Ali, Bill Russell
Jackie Robinson,
all of whom were people that
I met and I admired them
for what they achieved
as athletes but also
for the strength and dignity
that they showed the country
as black Americans.
That made me feel proud to b
a black American,
and it's something
that inspired me.
And when Muhammad Ali got on
the wrong side of the law
because he opposed
the Vietnam War,
I was going to be there for him.
You know, because I knew tha
his insights into it
were accurate
and that what he felt
was pretty much on the money
-You mentioned in the clip tha
you met Martin Luther King
We have a picture of you
with him here.
What was that experience like?
-Oh, that was incredible.
You know, I got to ask --
I was involved in
a summer mentoring worksho
and involved in journalism
So I got to cover Dr. King's
address to the mentoring group
with the national press
that followed him.
He'd been elected
Man of the Year in 1963,
and this was summer of 1964.
You know, this was at a time
when I more or less kind o
related to Malcolm X
more so than Dr. King
because you get emotional
when you see your people
abused and everything.
I wanted to retaliate, but
Dr. King helped us understan
that by nonviolence,
we're able to expose the bully
for who he is and just make it
impossible for his agenda
to be taken seriously,
and this eventually worked for
black Americans.
But it took a lot of courage
and patience and, you know
just that one incident helped me
get around
to understanding that.
-You wrote about
the Black Lives Matter momen
that happened last summer
and about how it gave you
tears of hope, but often
tears of hope can turn int
tears of rage
and tears of frustration.
Looking back at last summer, d
you have optimism in so far as
what direction we're headed?
-Well, I think last summer
really gave us a moment
of being able
to understand each other.
After people saw what happened
to George Floyd and realized
that this is what black
Americans had been speaking of
for 400 years, it probably was
a moment of insight
for Americans of all stripes
And I think that has given u
a chance to actually deal with
the issue of racism
and the denial of equal rights
It was actually fortunate
that people saw that
because now, no one can deny
something that is that obvious
No one can deny that, and
think we will be better of
because of the doors and bridges
that were built
and the doors that were opened
by that moment.
-You wrote about that.
You've written several essays.
You've written works of fiction.
You've written for television.
Did you know writing was a skill
you had around the same time
you realized basketball
was a skill you had?
-Well, you know, I was
an English major at UCLA,
but you don't know how far
you're going to get with it.
I also dabbled in history,
so, you know, I guess
joining the two discipline
really has been something
that has given me a voice.
-One of your writing credits
people might be less aware o
is that you wrote for the
television show "Veronica Mars."
How was that experience?
-Yes, I did.
Actually, it was really good
for me as a writer because
it teaches you how you have to
structure the story
and how to make sense
from one end to the other
or people will lose interest
and, you know, people won'
finish your book
or finish watching your movie.
So I found it was
a great learning experience.
Glad to see it on my résumé.
-The NBA announced this year
that they are going to award
the Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
Social Justice Champion Award.
How does it feel, you know, fo
everything you did on the court,
to have an award named for
the work you did off of it
-It's a great honor to hav
an award that rewards activism
I think the young men in the NBA
will, you know, use these awards
to figure out good things to d
with them and help continu
to spread the word about
what's right and what's wrong.
So this will give a lot of
people the incentive to se
what they can do to improv
their communities,
and I think it will bear
a lot of good fruit.
-Finally, I do want to
ask about --
I think this maybe was
the first time I saw you.
I think before I even saw yo
play basketball,
I saw you in "Airplane!"
And then I was very impresse
that someone that funny wa
also as good at basketball
as you were.
Do people still approach you
and ask you about this movie
-Well, you know,
I've lost all my hair
so they don't recognize me
anymore.
[ Laughter ]
But you know what's funny?
The guy in that picture,
the kid, I ran into his wife
You know, he's in his 40s now,
and I ran into his wife
in the airport,
and I was like, "What? Who?"
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Well, it's great.
It's nice to know
people still recognize you
for that great effort
as well as everything else
and thank you so much
for making the time
and being with us today, Kareem.
-Great talking to you.
-"Fight the Power: The Movements
That Changed America" premiere
on the History Channel
June 19th.